So we begin with the Paradise,
um,
which clearly is different from the
earthly paradise to paradises. We,
we went through the earthly
paradise. This is, uh,
whenever we begin the third Cantica,
which is called the paradise.
And this should read,
use find that Dante uses eh Ptolemaic,
um,
structure of the cosmos.
Atomic structure means that,
uh, for him, as for Ptolemy,
the earth is at the
center of the universe,
um,
unmoved immobile,
and there are a number of,
uh,
seven planets that circling around it.
The moon is thought of as
a planet, Mercury, the sun,
then there will be Mars,
Jupiter,
and Saturn. Beyond that, there is this,
the heaven of the so called fixed stars.
And beyond that the, uh,
premium, the Imperian,
the heaven or fire from which all motion,
uh,
begins, uh, from which time
starts. That's really where they,
the, the roots of time, uh, our, our, uh,
found and they stretch
out into the finite world,
uh, so that we really are in the
shadows of the leaves of time,
uh, which means that they
are, uh, all is falling and,
uh, being, uh, being replaced. Um,
but another thing you have to keep in
mind as you go into paradise is that, uh,
uh, Dante links the, uh,
each of the planets with, I
have said this before, I know,
but it bears repeating, uh,
with one of the liberal arts,
uh,
and their respectively.
The liberal arts are the seven
liberal arts. And then there were the,
there are two more's in
say, nine heavens, uh,
begins with grammar in
the planet of the moon.
And so you will have to expect that you
will find the language of Grammarians
Grammar, uh, the moon and
grandma, the, the, um,
if a very wide definition or what
grammar can be. It includes poetry,
includes history, even include
some rhetorical tropes, um,
and then the heaven of, uh, of,
of mercury with dialectics.
And so you're expecting to find the
language of dialectics deployed and it's
going to be the, uh, deployed
throughout the Canto,
the having of Venus and rhetoric that
probably is the least surprising,
uh, arrows and rhetoric. Uh,
I have an old a kinship.
They seem to each other.
Then they have enough Mars,
the god of war,
which he had Dante couples
with music in the persuasion.
That music is a harmony made
off of discordant parts.
So that there is a,
is kind of the same time simultaneously
a pool and a strife within the heaven
of, uh, of Mars. So that
old music then beyond that,
there's geometry, uh, linked with, uh,
the temperateness of Jupiter and
beyond that astronomy and or Saturn,
uh, they haven't really fixed
stars is tide is linked to, um,
ethics.
Whereas the heaven of the Imperian is
really the heaven of metaphysics is Dante,
we'll call it. And it will see
the kind of interesting, uh, uh,
arguments that Dante we'll
have because in effect is,
has changed his mind in when writing
the philosophical text known as the
banquet. Uh, you know, now the
come Viveo he writes it in Italian.
Uh,
he had a really claimed that ethics is
the first or the most important of the
arts. It's really the,
the, the discipline tote,
which all the are to chose other
arts are subordinated and Toad,
which they all points when
Dante writes the Paradiso,
he has changed his mind about that.
Though.
He also knows that in many ways
you cannot quite separate ethics,
whatever he means by ethics with
some theory about how the world is,
they really are inseparable. And
Dante, we'll go on back and forth in a,
in a re, uh, configuring
the relation of those two,
uh, uh, disciplines. The
other thing that I, uh,
I should mention before
we go on is that, uh, uh,
much of the Paradiso
really, uh, it's, it's,
it's going to come through as a way of,
is it teaching?
Uh, it's already implied that this
should be the thrust of Paradiso,
but the very idea that, uh, the,
there is the disposition of the arts
and sciences in through parties,
which means that the journey that Dante,
we'll have this cosmological journey.
It's an interplanetary German, he
goes from planet to planet, uh,
is already, Eh, an educational journey.
That's so he goes through grammar,
rhetoric, dialectic, et Cetera, et cetera.
Til He reaches a metaphysics or,
and beyond that there will be theology.
Uh, so it's, uh, it's,
it's, it's literally a,
an educational journey.
And this is already understood.
Those words already carried
out by the focus on, uh,
the teaching that Beatrice will deliver.
So I have to say a couple of things that
Danfoss teacher in paradise and this
is,
is an innovative,
very imaginative and
highly unusual move on.
The part of a port is not some kind of
abstract matron called Dame philosophy.
It's not some kind of allegory of nature.
You know,
you do have this kind of allegorical,
didactic categories where
nature appears as a, uh,
larger,
the disheveled woman wounded egos
because nature is fallen teaching.
Uh, the, the, the, the, the pilgrim or,
or that or that or the tray
or the traveler about the
secrets of nature and the
wealth of nature. Here
is a personal, uh, his,
his girlfriend to be sure.
And it's someone who also replaces all
the other likely candidates for this
teaching,
which is w would be Aquinas,
a boy he'd used to Bonaventure Oh,
figures that he's going to meet. Um,
it's a mistake to believe however,
that as some great scholars or
of Dante have said in the past,
the police was really a journey to
be a Trish. That's what they did say.
That's not the case because
Beatrice will disappear from,
she would still be within view,
up to a point in, in, in paradise.
But a role ends with Canto 30 of Paradiso.
And that from that point on,
a mistake by the name of Bernard,
the historical figure,
Bernard of Clairvaux will take place.
So this leads me now to
a further clarification.
Um,
they may be the tendency in some of you
to view the [inaudible] as some kind of
account to the mystical
experience. Uh, you know what, I'm,
what I'm saying that Dante sort of goes
beyond his own self beyond and the idea
of rational understanding of the world.
They're so rendering of
his own subjectivity to
some insight into the whole
this, I don't think that this
is what's happening here. Dante,
we'll preserve his rationality and his
sense of distinction and separation from
some kind of cosmic or cosmological
and cosmic hall till the very end.
Uh, there is a way in which Dante
we'll deploy the language of the,
of the mistakes.
And I want to give you some evidence of
that because I think that it opens up an
interesting chapter for your further
readings. Uh, but it's, he's not,
this is not to be read as a kind of
subscription of a mystical experience,
uh,
where the text then goes on in some
kind of a random approximation or random
copying of what the mistake.
So,
and becomes ineffable.
Dante uses occasionally if toward
the end the language of ineffability.
But this is,
remains a poetic construction and
imaginative projection into where it is a
journey into the absolute unknown,
into a space.
No other imagination had
really traveled and if those,
and have been those who had traveled
there, but they never really took,
came back to tell us Dante,
we'll play with that.
His is to use that language
and kind of a way of,
of getting into that which had
been left inarticulate and silent.
It's really largely a
battle against, uh, the,
the, um, for a poet threatening
a boundaries of silence.
Something that threatens him
with, uh, with uh, uh, uh,
with the defeat.
He will not be able to speak.
And from one point of view that the
feed for the Christian could also be of
course a victory,
but Dante is suspended between the two,
the two poles.
If I had to define,
and I have already given a kind of general
definition or what kind of ages and
which rubric, uh, should we
try to go on reading? Uh,
this part of the poem, I really
think this is, um, uh, is,
is really a poem about beauty,
uh, in the sense that, uh,
uh, Dante Hill tried to
understand what the beauty is.
Beauty is the visibility of,
of Patina says this. It's the,
the visibility of being,
he calls it being life.
The whole of life becomes visible only
because we have perceptions and images of
it. So it's, it's, I think
that Dante's trying to, uh, to,
to see that, to explore, uh,
what is that lies beyond that
which we see, um, what is,
is this beauty skin deep is it were,
because that's really one of the
dangers of focusing on beauty.
That it's really the surface of things,
the appearance of things. And, and,
and he will go between appearances,
images,
and some s in the idea that there
are essences are lying beyond them.
Um, okay. So I really
have said more or less,
all I had to say in the mode of,
uh,
of an introduction and I
immediately get into the, uh,
can't have one. Uh, let me just read,
Canto one a little bit with,
in some detail
the glory.
That's the way it starts.
The glory of Him who moves all things
penetrates the universe and shines in one
part more and in another less.
That's the first tercet
famous for [inaudible].
And I will read this in Italian
so that you sense how even the,
the rhythm, the rhythm of, of, of,
of the poem completely changes the rhythm
and even the syntactical structure of
the poem because you made
a call and I say this, uh,
knowing that you have
already noticed that,
that if you read Canto one of him fair,
no,
or Canto Wando purgatory did to exhort
idioms of the other canticles you know,
that the poet is immediately casting
himself into the role of the agent.
Right in the middle of the journey of
my life, I found myself that's really,
uh,
the very start of in fair no
one and in purgatory or to, uh,
uh, to course of a
better waters, the ship,
the boat of my genius now
goes and I were saying,
you remember not so in paradise or there
is a way in which immediately the first
tercet which has a car.
So to premial value, uh,
seeks to bracket the idea of the self
and the idea of the subjectivity.
It emphasizes the question of uh,
uh,
what God becomes the agent here is to
say it in a very direct as director,
the season says the glory.
It's a circumlocution once again,
but let me read it in Italian so that I
can, I can give you a sense, as I said,
of the new music that he has
found a new sense of, uh,
the in the Harmoni that toad
which language you have to, uh,
strive La Gloria the curoil to move
the Loonie Val's so pay and they try to
respond in an Aperitif view,
a I'll trough.
That's it. And it's rendered very,
very faithfully by Saint Claire.
I Dunno the other translations,
but probably they can deviate from edge,
but very much, and I read it in
Italian because I also would like you,
and this is understandable to the eye,
if not just to the ear for you, uh,
how he's playing with in line one,
the glory of Him who,
or moves. So God, the mover, I'll talk
about it in a little more. The, the, the,
the one who moves all in that,
oh,
then becomes one in the next line universe
or the old becomes a that which has
turned into one. That's what the
team logically the universe. Uh,
and then, uh, it goes on,
pen penetrates and uh,
uh, the university and shines in
one part more and in another less,
um, well, uh, the thirst it casts.
Um, God, Oh,
this is about God as a circumlocution.
He's not a,
it's really a god who is visible
through God's effects. Uh,
is God appears,
is kind of course now.
Then if you really understand the
effects it means is a causality.
I don't want to get into too much
into that, but you know what I mean?
That simple. You only know the
effects. You know the glory.
We see the glory, which is the
light glory. It's a semantic for us.
The first thing we have to
say, this is a, Eh, a shift,
a change in the history of the word.
That's what poets do. What it was.
The poets invent reinvent language.
That's largely what they do. They
change the meaning of words. Glory.
In the classical time and all the way
down to the renaissance in the romantic
age, our glory means, uh,
it means fame in sees the child of clear,
I mean the,
the power we have to survive now try the
posthumous life because whatever noble
deeds heroes may have achieved,
that's not what it means here.
Glory means light. It's like, of course
they're light to once fame if you wish.
But this is the light and fast.
And why do we know that?
Because light now is linked to two verbs
of the glory of Him who all think moves
all things, uh, penetrates
the universe and shines.
So you see there is says there's a
metaphor of light that is conveyed here.
So the first Tercet, uh,
presents God in the, in a,
in a cosmological row,
which is double one of motion
and one of light to things. It,
he come,
Dante's combining.
And that is still telian idea
of God as the prime mover,
the one who imparts motion to all things.
And the second image is that of God as
the principal of light and neoplatonic
idea.
So He's fusing together.
Two contradictory apparently
contradictory traditions,
light emotion.
One is talking in terms of causality.
And the other one really, I'm not going
to go much, much further than this.
The other one in terms of,
because light does that penetrates,
shines all over,
uh,
according to a principle of hierarchy
more unless there is no uniformity in and
with light. And I'll come back
to this notion in a moment. Uh,
but so one idea cast God is the prime
mover according to the tradition of
restore telian philosophy.
The other one thinks of God as in
the mode of light or participation.
They are two different theological modes.
God participates is part
of creation, right? Uh,
the natural world is part
of the supernatural world.
It's not just a causality,
uh, the course begins or
things and then somehow, uh,
retreats in some sorts
of, uh, uh, invisible, uh,
and unknown, uh, uh,
non space or of its own.
Uh, the other, uh, item and this,
the first tercet is that of the,
that I want to emphasize is
the principle of hierarchy.
Light shines more and less. Uh,
I have been hinting at this,
this is really a great problem for Dante
in, in, in other parts of the poem,
you remember two course
over better waters,
Dante says in Purgatorio one, and that
implies of course, that there are bad,
good, better, best, uh, that we
are in the principle of hierarchy.
Differences are very crucial for
Dante because they, they, they,
they allow us to know things. Only two
differences. And also the, because,
uh,
this,
this differences and that's the value
of hierarchy are still combined in some
way. Some kind of unified, uh, structure.
Hierarchy is a structure that unifies all
differences according to the principle
of degree. Uh, more of this a
little bit later as we go on.
And then Dante, now, uh,
I said he's not a mystic subjectivities
not erased that mistakes.
10 though they all claim a unique vision,
they all end up resembling each other.
When they talk about the ineffable.
Dan Introduces now the
subject and he says,
I was in the heaven that
most receives is light.
There is to say past in the Imperian,
which is sort of spiritual,
uh,
he was in as close to God as it can be,
a which will also be as
far from God as it can be.
Um,
uh,
I was in the heaven that most receives
his light and I sold things which he,
that descends from it has not the
knowledge of the power to tell again.
So,
uh,
no sooner does Dante introduce
his subjectivity as and,
and his, his, uh,
a way of knowing and the are
this intimacy of closeness to,
to the,
the,
the beatific vision than he has
also to cast himself as a visionary,
has no knowledge or the power to,
I saw things and you will see how
Dante goes or refining his eyesight.
A little detail that you might really
enjoy is that we do know that Dante would
use lenses, glasses, uh, toward the
end of the had just been invented.
You know, there are books written
about when we're a glasses in the,
whether they invented in piza
where they invaded in Padua.
There have been wars
going on about this claim,
but then he uses uses glasses.
So he really had difficulty.
That's the point in seeing and the whole
of Paradiso is about the refinement of
site and the refinement of vision.
How you're going to be able to, a,
to attune as it were, your eyes to
the objects that aren't you. Anyway,
he cast himself. Now he's a visionary
with an internal vision. You know, it's,
I'm not casting him as a homer who is
blind that therefore he sees everything
with the inner thigh, but he wants
to be a visionary report and they,
so things which this to say,
one who sees things as a whole.
That's what the difference between
ear, you know, there are great,
great debates within the ear and AI is
that the ear you hear and you hear all
this old for bomb in the,
in the linear way and all the
things can come from all sides,
but you can only catch a thing at a
time with the eye. You have the eyes,
the Olgan gives you the chance to the
old one of the contemplative gives you a
chance to see, uh, totalities I ISO
things which she had the sense from.
It has not the knowledge
of the power to tell again.
And then he explains why he explains
to the status of his poetic language.
I, so what is the relationship between
language and vision? That's the,
if you want to put it
in a very abstract way,
how are the two related
to farther intellect?
Joy near to its desire? Uh, intellect, uh,
yearns longs for the
object that it desires.
So there is a desire of
the mind that desire.
It's not just the desire of
the up intellectual desires.
A sink so deep that memory can
not follow it. Very simple.
Forgetfulness intervenes so that the,
he may have an intuition
and insight into things.
He can not quite go on a
recalling what it nevertheless,
so much of the Holly Kingdom is,
I was able to treasury,
my mind shall now be matter of my song.
So whatever he's going to tell us is
literally a shadow of things he manages to
remember.
And it makes sense that he should not
remember because part one of the paradoxes
of this political structure is the
following you. He has a beatific vision.
How can he retain in his mind,
the site which is finite,
that which is infinite,
if not through vestiges and if
not through through shadows.
You know, how can you, how can my memory,
which is, which is a metaphor of time,
right? By definition, I
remember certain things,
but how can I go on remembering and
holding that which is without time,
which is infinite.
So the first paradox of,
in the representation of Paradise,
let me go on with the next one.
Next paragraph.
Now,
Dante turned to the god of poets to a
Polo or good Apollo for the last labor
make me such a vessel of
their power. Ah, he's, he's,
he cast himself into a passive
mode vessel one who receives,
uh, he's, he's, it's, it's the
language of, uh, of restraint.
It's a language robe holding back.
It's, it's, uh, it's in a sense,
it's really the classical are
commonplace, you know, of, of, uh,
asking the muse to breathe through
us. You know, sing to me your muse.
Remember, uh, the, uh, the, the,
the, the, the Elian, uh, uh,
in this, hey, I'm a
variant of the same thing.
A variation of the same thing
happens in the office. Oh, good.
I apologize for the last label. Make
me such a vessel. That power is,
that requires for the gift
of their loved Laurel.
What an extraordinary image.
This is a remembering the story
of the God who chases Daphne.
The object of his desire. We
chicken, not really obtain,
that's the stolen, you all know
the story in the metamorphosis,
but he can only obtain, uh,
Daphne, which means lower in Greek,
but he only killed, contain
this young maiden, uh, uh,
Daphne in the form of a
metaphor for the Laurel crown.
So it's a sort of a journey,
which is somehow, uh,
the object of which becomes the
procession of the object becomes the,
becomes this located not quite
what the God himself wanted.
But this introduces something
else about the, the, the,
the Paradiso thus far,
the one peak of per Nassis has to face me.
You may remember this is a recall of the
dream of Parnassus in purgatory that we
saw when the stations and Virgil were
flattered into believing that what they
had dreamt is actually the,
the, the simulacrum of the,
of the earthly paradise.
That's where the one pecan for NASA says,
suffice me.
But now I have need of both
language of humility, um,
entering into the arena
and the arena that remains.
He's a struggle. Now. First of all,
they had introduced this image of
himself as a vessel receptive to the,
uh, inspiration of Apollo. Now,
the language of even violence into
the arena where there's a sports,
whether it's is, uh, battles are
fought, enter into the arena.
Now entering on the arena that remains.
And now look at this,
come into my breasts and breathe there
as when thou Jewess Marcis from the
Scabbard of his limbs,
uh,
an echo of the struggle
between the poet and the God.
He does not want to be like Marcis
because Marsha's Harold presumption.
So that's now you understand the language
of restraint and withholding the Lang,
I will presumption Marcis had tried to
outdo a Apollo and of course was defeated
by a polo and flayed by Apollo.
Dante is not want to,
but this is about is the fear in the
battle for the description of paradise.
That the fear that he may
be usurping God's role,
the fear that he may be transgressing
and violating that which is the,
uh, the sovereign claim of, of
the gods. So he continues now,
or power divine. So that's
one of the, uh, images of a,
a fear of blast for me.
Fear of transgression.
And this will continue to them about the
possibility of Hubris, in other words.
And then it continues our power divine,
if they'll granted me so much of myself
that I made sure for the shadow of the
blessed kingdom imprinted in my brain,
thou shall see me come
to the chosen three,
call rule and crown myself.
Then with those leaves are which the
theme and thou will make me worthy.
So seldom father are there gathered
for triumph of Caesar or poet.
Falton shame of human wheels.
That opinion bowel must be get gladness
in the glad Delphic God when it makes
any, any long for it, a great
frame for falls, huddle, spark,
uh, etc. And then the lamp of the
world, I'm just give you this, uh,
uh, Dante is, uh, uh, approaching,
uh, he's moving. He thinks
he's on earth. Uh, and,
and he discovers that I will not
go on into to details in the,
he discovers that his, uh,
uh, on, uh, uh, heaven,
uh, in, in, in, on the moon.
Uh, so he describes here,
this is the image at the bottom.
Page 21 line 65.
And following Beatrice stood with her
eyes fixed only on the terminal wheels and
on. Ha, I fixed mine, withdrawn
from above at her aspect.
I was changed within as was globalist
when he tasted of the herbs that made him
one among the other gods
in the sea. Uh, it's,
it's a story of,
uh,
clearly the pilgrim is moving into another
level of experience and our level of
being and hearing remarks
on the transformation that
he is undergoing and the,
the, the emphasis falls in the
distance between the UVD an account of,
of,
of uh,
Glaukos who believes that he's immortal
and jumps into the water of the tasting
of some herbs.
And Dante himself is indicated by
that little preposition within the
transformation occurs in
Dante from within himself.
No in some literal way
outside, uh, on the outside.
And then he continues the passing beyond
humanity cannot be set forth and words
that the examples of Pfizer therefore
for whom to cook, for him to embrace,
uh, reserves. The experience,
experience the pilgrim is having
is unique and irreducible.
And the poem,
we can only be read as an example,
as an account of, uh, of,
uh, what has happened to him.
And then he continues.
If I was only the part of me,
which that creates this last thou
knowest love who goes to heaven,
who with Dai flight did raise me and your,
your, your notes. Your footnotes
will tell you that this is a, uh,
a reference to the second letter
to the Corinthians chapter 12.
Bye Paul. Bye. Same Paul, uh, with uh,
he also tells the story of um,
uh,
his, uh, being wrapped
to the third heaven.
So
we have the two accounts
and Canto one of, of, of,
of experiences.
One is that of a,
of encounters with a divine. One is
that of the profit nation by marshes.
And the other one leaves by saying,
Paul, who is, you recall Dante, uh, uh,
casts as one of the
possible models for him.
Says when at the beginning he has
to set out from the Jordan says,
I'm not an ears. I'm not poor. Now we
see how Paul comes into play. Who am I?
Then that was the whole thrust of
the point. What happens to Paul?
Paul goes to the third
heaven. Uh, and, and, and,
and people have a way of a head away in
the Middle Ages especially said why many
have inside of their, uh, you know,
the third heaven and what is meant by
the third heaven was the third modal
vision.
There are levels of vision
that they emphasize that is
a literal level. Uh, the,
the carnal worldly level.
There's an imaginative vision.
And then there is the ecstatic
vision that Paul our head.
But the think is that the second letter
to the Corinthians is the Paul went to
the third heaven head. The,
the, the, the vision of God,
the beatific vision he returned
and could not speak about it,
hit it because what he saw had
to be kept wrapped in silence.
So this is now Dante is between,
uh,
on the one hand Marcis and that
funeral definition. And now Paul,
it is as if he also is
transgressing the teaching of Paul.
That the whole of paradise is about
limits and the possibility of establishing
clear limits.
He will do what Paul himself could not do.
Paul kept quiet in the belief that the
silence was the proper language of this.
His sublime experience. Dante,
we'll go on speaking pill.
It's possible to him to do so. The
final, he really has forgotten, uh,
everything that I've seen. So you see
how he's casting himself, his own point,
the powers, his own subjectivity
between two different modalities.
He doesn't want to go as
presumptuously far as Marcy has did.
He does not one tool
retreat as a s a s Paul did.
Okay. Uh, I really think that
I should let you know. No,
I take a little digression before we
go into the second part of the Canto.
Okay.
And Ken to one and two where Dante is
really going to face a peculiar issue.
The universe. I mean, is it a
material universe that's the,
that's the, the, the,
the thrust Canton tool.
Is this a natural than part
of the natural world or not?
Cause I'm talking about the spots on the
moon, that's Cetera. We'll come to that.
Um, and here in Canton one was just see
that he's going to discuss the, the,
the arrangement of, of the
cosmos. But you have to know.
I want you to too. I want to to, uh,
share with you a couple of paragraphs
of a letter that Dante writes,
uh, to introduce paradise.
This is what had happened. Um,
he lives in Ravenna when he's writing.
He's probably [inaudible] at the time.
He writes, uh, the earthly
paradise as you know,
he makes references to the garden of
Eden in terms of the park, the pine wood,
the wood or pine trees
around the city. Um, uh,
we do know that he will
live and die in Ravenna, uh,
but he decides to send the first
10 cantors paradise to the,
uh, so called, uh, can, uh, the, the,
the great dog of Verona who had been
his patron for a number of years.
And he introduces his 10 cancers
that his ends with a letter code.
The letter to, uh, can grant the anytime
they say Dante writes, I, you know,
that this is the 10th letter over a number
of letters that he writes. This is, uh,
this is the, uh, let me
just read this. This, uh,
um,
it's a kind of glossing.
It explains the genre of the
poem, explains what his, uh,
um, models have been, how has to be read.
But look what he says about this, uh, uh,
circumlocution here, um,
about Paul the apostle.
They feel this is from paragraph 27.
It's not a really long letter,
but I couldn't read the whole thing
with uh, uh, putting y'all to sleep.
The philosopher presents an argument
constant with the above in the first book
on, on Heaven, uh, the
philosophy of meaning at a store
too. Well, he says that I,
heaven quote,
has material more normal than
that of other heavens beneath it.
To the extent it has this more distance,
then they from the earth and ability,
uh,
in a hierarchical structure,
the nobility of matter,
it will depend on its
proximity to the source of, uh,
of a, of light and life.
Uh, okay. And to this,
and too,
this might be added with the Apostle
Paul told the Ephesians concerning Christ
who was centered above all the
heavens that he might fill all things.
This is the heaven of the olds.
Pleasures to which pleasures at
Gq refers in accusing Lucifer.
Thou was the seal of resemblance,
full of wisdom and perfect in beauty that
was in the pleasure of the paradise of
God and after having said in the silicon
persecution that he wasn't that part of
paradise,
he continues meaning he meaning I himself
by stating that he sold things which
he will descends sense,
cannot relate and it gives the cause of
they're saying that the intellect goes
so deeply into its desire itself,
which is God that the memory cannot
follow to understand what this means,
it should be noted that in this life,
the human intellect,
because of the affinity test
for the separated intellectual
substance with which
it shares its nature reaches such a
height of exaltation when it is Exalted,
that upon his return to itself having
transcended the order of the capacity of
men,
memory fails and this idea is implied
to us by the apostle addressing the
Corinthians passage. Just read where
he writes, quote, I know a man,
whether in the body or out
of the body, I no, no god,
no with who was caught up to the third
heaven and who heard secret words,
who it is not granted to men,
which is not granted to men,
to Arthur c when the intellect had passed
beyond the bounds of human capacity
and its exhortation, it could not remember
what happened outside these bounds.
And the same idea implied to us in Matthew
where the three disciples fell down
on their faces and told nothing about
it afterwards as if they had forgotten.
And it is written in the GQ quote I
saw and I fell upon my face and quote,
but if the PA, this passage is not satisfy
the skeptical, let them read Richard,
have some victor in his
book on contemplation or
Bernard of Clairvaux in his
book on consideration or Augustan in
his book on the capacity of the soul and
there will be no longer skeptical or
if they should bark out against the
possibility of such exaltation
because the sinfulness of the speaker,
they should read Daniel where they would
find that even the book of Donna's Sir
by divine permission,
so something which was a
warning two centers and then
forgot it for he who makes
the sun to rise upon the good and bad
a rain it upon the Justin the adjust
manifest his glory to the living,
no matter how evil they are sometimes
mercifully for the sake of the conversion,
sometimes harshly it as a punishment and
to a greater or less degree according
to his will.
And the reason why I want to share
this passage with you is that it really
places a with some clarity itch.
It casts it projects a light of a that
makes things clear about this state.
The status of the poem,
the poem involved a number of models
which are all in the contemplative
philosophical tradition or again,
it's not a stool,
the prophetic tradition,
but he makes them agree with
the same mode of the visionary,
you know, you see, that's
what the profits do.
They see in order to speak.
He has no you,
if your readers of the Bible,
you probably have heard, uh,
you may be right.
If we were to believe that there really
is no necessary link in the Bible
between vision,
between the mistakes,
those have visions and
those who are profits.
They are two different experiences,
two different states,
not so for Dante. It may be true, uh, in,
in the Bible that they are to Dante
things that they too will go to air,
that you have vision in order to speak.
And that's really what the,
so it helps us understand
the sense of, uh, of, of, of,
of poetry with which, which Dante invokes
here at the beginning of Paradiso.
Let me go now. Uh, Dante has to go on, uh,
tries to find out landlines
900. So, uh, or so, uh,
uh, how, uh, us a question about,
uh, uh, what has been happening
to him now. I said, been moving.
He thought it was on earth and the Earth,
earthly paradise.
Now he seems to be on another,
on another planet. Client 95.
If I was freed from my perplexity,
um,
Beatrice dismisses some fancies of is
you make the surf dog with false Dan
fancies, sort of cannot see is the
woods, if that had cast them off,
you are no longer on earth as you think,
but lightening flying from its
own place never ran so fast.
Is that return to dine the journey?
Dantes is traveling so fast,
the speed of light to go from
the earthly paradise to the moon.
If I was freed from my
perplexity, um, dope,
but the brief words, she smiled to
me, I was more entangled in a new one.
And I said I was content already
resting from a great wonder,
but now I wonder how I should be
rising above this light substances.
Um, two, three things. One, uh,
that I, I should, I should,
I should mention to you and that will
never mention them again, but better.
This was all or unfolds the whole,
the,
the narrative economy with the pilgrim
experience in perplexities in doubt,
which Beatrice will clarify.
And in turn those questions,
those, those, those, those responses
go on triggering new doubt.
So it's really a question of, uh, uh,
doubts answers in an unending process
of the mind and lodging and large in
itself and always filled with wonder.
And that's really the language that I want
to start emphasizing for you here. Uh,
how Dante's using this figure of
admiration recalls at line 97,
or I was content resting
from a great wonder. Now,
why wonder and, uh, uh, this will, uh,
you will see continues throughout
the beginning of, uh, of, of,
of, of Paradise. What is this
wonder? It is, first of all,
a definition of the
aesthetics of paradise.
Wonder translates the Latin,
uh,
Admin Rasia uh, that's the Italian
word in English. Admiration,
uh,
which actually is to be understood at me.
Roseo the Lathan English admiration.
But for, for the Middle Ages,
it's nothing less than the sublime.
If you wanted to translate the medieval
era and mid axial or alliteration into
an equivalent English and aesthetic
English term would be the sublime,
the suit of the United States ideas.
[inaudible] it's not a romantic
idea is probably you are,
you're led to believe it's
an old idea. It's the, uh,
it's a Greek notion of indicating
the mind that is overwhelmed with the
spectacle of things that do wharf.
The mind thinks that the mind cannot
quite comprehend. That's the sobriety.
They can be the sublime in nature.
They can be the sublime and in
arts they can be other forms.
And the Sublime Dantas
mode of paradise is indeed.
This is the oscillation of a mind
that is opening up full of doubts,
which really now that's what he
becomes subjective, critical.
And then the experience with
sublime overwhelming him, uh,
uh,
show.
But this idea of the sublime now
introduces a picture of the universe,
the way Beatrice will deliver it.
She therefore, after a sigh of pity,
I love her and I say, you know,
the way she's going to two, three, Dante,
like a child that is formed as a result,
a bent her eyes on me with a
look of a mother cat. Look,
her mother casts on her delirious child,
delirious in the theological sense.
I don't think that he's really actually
crazy delirious or the word English word.
We use delirium since me as simply
means getting off the furrow.
Leerom in Latin means the
furrow. Wherever you go off, uh,
the rat as it were or some or
the further you are tracing,
then you are delirious.
You are going off on your own in
some kind of a silly a direction.
And she began. That's the, the
first picture of the universe.
And we are going to find that this picture
is going to be refined in a number of
ways, but this is what
he can understand. Now.
All things whatsoever have
order among themselves.
That's the premise in Dante's costs
and they will just add for you.
And he continues.
She continues.
And this is the form that makes
the universe resemble God.
This is so, so that the universe
has enlightened us to the divinity,
to things to be said immediately.
The word order in case you don't know
it's or though that our deo means beauty,
it's idea that it's,
it's the symmetrical arrangement
of proportionate light,
full of light and clarity. Uh, um, uh,
structure of all of the whole order.
This,
even the word Pharma,
one of it means form means that
there is a shape to things,
but it translates the Latin
[inaudible] another synonym for beauty.
The picture of the universe that Dante,
that Beatrice evokes for
Dante is one of beauty. Um,
uh,
which in turn implies a vision because
beauties and they find that that was she
seen,
gives me pleasure.
This is the famous definition
of Aquinas that which has seen,
gives pressure. That's beauty. It's a
sort of subjective idea of beauty here.
Of course Beatrice thinks of an
objective order of the world. It's not,
it's not the fact that I like it. Only
though Aquinas also gives that, that,
that, that, that, uh,
explanation of beauty
that which scene pleases,
that implies a self, uh, it tastes
a personal taste and made the very,
very rich, medieval understanding
of the aesthetic experience.
But there is also an objective idea of
the whole universe laid out in older
shape clarity.
These are the proposed number,
proportion clarity.
These are the attributes of a,
of beauty. And this, this
cosmological do that. And just to,
with this line that the universe is,
resembles card seems to be such a nice
way of thinking about the universe.
But if you really think about it, it's
really a heretical proposition. You know,
the universe, it's like God, what about
the evil that there is in the universe?
Is the idea that there is a continuity
between God's transcendence and God's
eminence that says,
Hey,
I know that he's a little bit like
Marcis and he just doesn't like it.
He just likes to be a
little better than Paul.
There are at least he's going to talk,
but now this is really strange statement
and therefore has to be clarified.
And I think, uh, uh, she will,
I talk like this because I have to
explain that I just was looking at an old,
a great text of 'em in view
of my class today, last night.
It was really a great text by a Lovejoy.
So some of you may know him. It was a
great, one of the truly great inventor,
one can speak to this.
The whole idea of the history of ideas in,
in,
in the United States used to be a great
professor in the forties 50s and early
success at Johns Hopkins.
And he wrote a great book,
which I still advise people to
read the great chain of being.
Cause that's really the idea, you know,
the great chain of being. It's this,
that God is this great chain of being.
It's this a virtual,
a metaphor of the continuity between
the world of unity and the world of
multiplicity. And parality said, you know,
and it implies that we are on the,
uh,
that the whole universe
is this arrangement,
a chain and invisible chain.
It's an idea that reappears in the
18th century English literature. Pope,
for instance, he uses his, that I
read this in, in Lovejoy, uh, the,
uh,
but it also implies it's,
it's a strange idea as it
implies that the value of things,
the values of every entity depends on
the position one occupies in the various
rings of the chain so
that if you are an angel,
then you're really above,
uh,
above human beings were made
all bolt where beastly and
angelic at the same time.
We have this kind of paradoxical
quality of being spiritual,
an animal at the same time.
And then we are according to the idea,
don't,
some of you may doubt it.
We are better than dogs and dogs are
better than stones and so on is in a kind
of hierarchy, a system of degrees. And,
and he loved Joel goes on saying,
well,
this is really the moment when Dante has,
is adopting the idea of the great chain
of being and this great chain of being
makes him a really unorthodox.
I want to tell you that that's not true
because I think we should read more
carefully this passage.
This is the beginning here and
others about this resemblance. Uh,
the universal resemble God. Here
Beatrice continues to the high creatures.
See the impress of the
terminal excellence,
which is the end of which that system
itself is made in the older I speak of all
natures have their bands.
We all have our own specific gravity.
We're all drone. We have
done by our desires. We go,
we're, we're at desire,
uh, takes us desires.
And so there's a kind of natural instinct,
the natural movement in
this way in which a stone,
if you drop it for or risk to the
ground naturally because of its specific
gravity and the fire,
if you light a candle,
the fire will always go up.
Instinctively,
all things move according to their weight,
according the specific weight.
It's a spiritual gravity. Now,
are we like that? Is that really what
Dante is saying? That it seems easy?
He seems so that's where he seems to be
saying according to the different laws
and near to the source
and farther from it.
They move there for two different poles
over the great sea of being each with an
instant given to it,
to Barry wrong.
This bear fire up towards the moon.
Uh, this is by the way,
this is really the passage,
his lantus rewriting a passage
from Augustine's confessions.
This is the motive force
in more to creatures.
This binds the earth together and makes
it one and not only the creature that
with our intelligence as this bow shoot,
but also have intellect
and love meeting us.
We have intellect and love.
You know the,
remember the famous great poem from
about women who have intellect and law.
Now we all have, yeah, she
says, she says Internet,
the providence that regulates all this
mixed forever quiet with its light,
the heaven within which turns out of
the greatest speed on top of the Primo
Morbidity and didn't now as to a place,
a point of the power of the bow string is
bearing us which aims at a joyous mark.
It is true.
And now that's the correction
to Lovejoy's interpretation.
It is true that as a shape of and does
not accord with the arts intention
because the material is
definitely responsive.
So sometimes the creature having the
powders impelled to turn aside another way
deviates from his course and there's
fire maybe seem to fall from a cloud
lightened inc for instance,
like does not go always up tight,
can call also down.
Um,
and this farmer is far from my couch.
So the primary impulse
diverted by false pressure,
it turn to the earth.
In other words,
within this description of the order of
the cosmos be as it goes on to say that
human beings are the odd,
the old figures that we
somehow have the power to.
Did you deviate from this pattern
of order that we can undo?
We have this paradoxical freedom that
makes us are the stay within a particular
idea of what God may have meant
or really for us or really,
uh, uh, uh,
breach that particular or the human
beings are the certain elements in this
older portrait of the universe.
And that is the whole
statement of freedom.
So the Dante's removing
from a deterministic,
that w w that's what it would make it
into a heretical texts at idea of what are
the cosmo Moses. Then she turned her
face again to the sky. Let me go.
I was a little bit, uh,
quickly on or can to, to,
um, and so, uh, but I
will need a few minutes.
Came to to Dante now is in
the sphere of the moon. Um,
you know that and there'd
be a discussion on the spot.
This is whole medieval legend.
Uh,
if you look at the moon and full moon,
you see the dark spots and the legend was
that cane and the medieval legend that
cane, uh, running away from, uh, the,
the, the knowledge of the murder of
her, of his brother had actually,
uh, with the help of God that had removed
him from the earth and had taken refuge
there. And wherever we see there
is just the imprint of Cain.
Dante dismisses this legend. What
goes on talking about science. She,
Beatrice will have a scientific discourse.
And the question is,
is this unnatural cosmos or not?
Do we,
do we see shades on the moon simply
because they said density or,
uh, not orality, uh, of matter?
Or is it because it therefore light has
a way of going through this Ma matter of
the moon,
uh,
according to the principle or more
or less the radically and density?
Or is it because there's a different
way in which light is distributed?
The Solution Dante gives or Beatrice
will give? It's the second one.
We should the shadows on the moon simply
because I said different source of
light.
In other words,
the natural cosmos has to be
understood in terms of its metaphysics.
The physics has only can only be
understood in terms of metaphysics.
But what I want to stress to you is that
the natural and the supernatural are
always seen by Dante as
holding hands together.
There are not two separate worlds.
They're not two separate. Uh, uh,
they,
they mentioned that two different
ways of looking at the same,
at the same thing. But let's see
how he introduces the Cantor,
which I think is important for a number
of reasons came to true or you who in a
little bark.
The language of humility,
uh,
is suspects at this point because
we know that the sublime is,
uh, is the mode is the trope that
he will use or you in a little bark.
You, he's addressing us
is beginning a dressing.
Readers eager to listen,
um,
have followed behind my ship.
The singing makes her way turned
back to see your shores again.
Do not put fault on the
deep for perhaps losing me.
You would be left bewildered.
That waters I take what?
I never sailed before. Oh, that's uh,
it gives poignancy to the little bark.
It's a little bark and he was,
I'm doing such, I mighty. I'm
engaged. Such a magnificent,
extraordinary adventure.
Right?
The one is the take we're never seal
before. Minerva breeds are polar pilots.
Me and the nine busers show me the
bears and then a restriction of the,
the children's that he has been
addressing. You are the few, uh,
kind of reductive apostrophe.
The very few here. The,
it's the lucky,
I'm the lucky [inaudible] he would say,
have you guys a very few really know and
are interested in the mysteries in the,
in the most esoteric,
uh,
hurricane sciences that he's
going to put out here. Uh,
you are the few that
reached out early that
the language actually says turn your neck.
Uh,
this is really poor translation.
I don't know what other,
um, since later say, uh,
you are the few who turn your
neck because it's the whole idea.
Uh, another form of presumption.
You, you may have heard,
you may recall in the Bible,
but the stiff neck, right?
The definitely the,
of course the neck is always the emblem
of conversion when you want to, when you,
for Plato, you reach a conversion.
You really turn the neck.
That's how you do toward a, not for
Dante that he turned upside down, but in,
in play to you turn the neck and you
know where the source of light is.
The Biblical counter to that is the,
maybe the,
the stiff neck,
those who do not,
who lack humility right
behind this metaphor.
That is the whole idea that
what makes a human being,
what confers dignity to a human being
is the power that we among all animals
have to look up at the sky and see and
look at the stars and therefore wonder
all other animals are always looking
down, right? We are alone. Of course,
there are other people who believe that
what makes human beings give particular
dignity to human beings is something else.
The of all of them as those who
said that we speak of course,
but they have all of them.
The one I really like is that
we are capable of laughing. Uh,
that's the exploration. It's
an Aristotelian idea, but
it's exploration of, uh, of,
of, of comedy. Uh, to hear.
It's that that's the illusion
though. You have who feel,
who could be also implying like me
that do not be too arrogant about this.
Who reached out early for angels,
bread,
knowledge for knowledge by which
men here live but never come from.
It's satisfied.
You may indeed put forth your vessel on
the salt that holding my furrow before
the water returns smooth.
Again,
those glorious ones who crossed the
sea to call Chris. We're not amazed.
Once again, the language of
admiration, that language is sublime.
Or can I come to this in a moment as you
shall be when the they sold Jason Turn.
Plowman okay. Um, well,
the metaphor of the journey by water
to describe now an real journey.
So an anti Dante is clearly thinking of
that metaphoric compression that we saw
in Ulysses. Remember the sailing
that became a mad flight.
Now here, if the flights that
becomes a ceiling, um, and,
and the notion that he's guiding us,
so the sense of his responsibility,
he's turning his back,
unlike Ulysses. Okay?
We dispose of that mythic
resonance, uh, very quickly.
But what he's really saying is
that the journey we're undertaking,
which is the reading of this book,
can become extraordinarily dangerous.
And why?
The reason why it becomes dangerous is
because he's traveling over water that
leaves no wake behind it.
This is the, the, the,
the what I would call the danger
of the seafaring in seafaring.
You have no preestablished roots.
There is nothing. There's no way,
no road, no path that can be
they're fixed then you can find.
So he's inviting us to
keep very close to him,
but we might be losing
him at the same time.
The journey by water is not exactly like
the journey by land because there are
no pre established
directions marked are for us.
And then finally this allusion to Jesus.
So he's not like a uterus.
This is like, like the,
the hero of the organoids who
has gone looking for the Golden,
the golden flees. And He, uh,
it's an image that he appears at the end
of Paradiso 33 where Dante has the god
Neptune from the depth wondering at
the extraordinary power of the human
imagination and the human will that
wonder at the heroics of Jason,
uh, telepathy owners without, uh,
he can't quite believe what he,
when he sees it's clearly an illusion
to a Dante himself is going to do in,
in, in, uh, seeing God face to face. And
then, uh, and then returning to the earth.
But what I want to emphasize
in the here really I will stop.
They'll give you a chance to
ask me some questions. The
is that we probably never read.
Uh,
I think we skipped Canto,
um, 18 of him. Fair?
No,
I think we did.
I don't think that I asked you to read
it and I don't presume that you would go
and read what I don't ask you to
read. So you, you never really did.
But in Cantwell 18, Dante, you there,
if you go and read Canto of inferno,
you will find Jason punished among the
flatters and the juicer because he's the
famous for seducing hips pile
and abandoning her. Okay.
It's a version of what happened.
Fees. You said media. It's,
it's one of the great fixation
Salva of Greek. Chuck,
one of the great situations of repeat
the situations of a Greek tragedy.
But the interesting thing is that
bumper now is distinguishing between the
ethical judgment of
Jason who is behind in,
in February team and the imaginative
aesthetic value of the adventure itself.
No.
Is he saying that if for that the good
and the Butte and the beautiful I really
two distinct things,
he's warning us about that.
And that's what I want to
pick up the conversation, uh,
next time where we are going to be
talking about the value of images and uh,
the ethics of images.
But let me finish here now and see if
there are some questions which I will try
to answer.
Please.
Turning your minds to the bread of angels.
And then he talks about the image of water
and all of those symbols that come in.
But it seems a little strange to me that
you're talking about translation did
that you're turning your mind to bread.
It's very strange.
I was just wondering if you could talk
about that symbolism or significance of
that is turn your mind.
The, the question is about
explaining, uh, the image of bread,
uh, in the beginning of
Canto two of paradise, uh,
where Dante says dressing the
readers that they are turning their,
uh, their, their neck, uh,
too early to the bread of angels.
Uh,
I have a question for you. What
we'll do. You find that strange?
Well, I have nine that instead
of turning your neck, but just,
okay. Oh, right. Okay. The, well,
the bread of angels.
So I would see the bread of angels and
the breadth of angels is his knowledge.
So I think that the implied,
uh, the, the, the, the,
the transference, the metaphorical
reading by Mandelbaum is accurate. Uh,
I wish it were a more
literal, um, but just justice.
I think that my own translation,
of course, saint clay are also,
it's one of the few times that he, he, he,
he, he, he deviates from the, the literal,
because the literal burden of the, of the
metaphor, uh, has a number of residences,
which I think are valuable. Like
exactly the stiff neck, the, the,
the turning of the neck,
uh, in, in the context,
in a context like paradise where
Dante starts out by clearly,
uh,
locating himself within some,
some contradictory possibilities,
the possibility of a transgression
or the possibility of, uh, uh,
trespassing in the case of, uh, of Paul.
So what exactly is he so
that that image is his,
his by the image of the, of the,
the turning of the neck, uh,
early for the bread of the angels is also
a reverberates with anxieties that he
has about his own adventure and a,
and his own enterprise.
That's,
I don't know if this answers
your perplexity but yes.
So the random angels
knowledge, uh, of angels is no
knowledge. Yeah. That, which,
you know,
the I the idea that you find
in the banquet that why,
why do philosophers,
what I'm sure that it's literally true
that there is nothing better for a great
philosophical conversation then,
you know,
a glass of wine and you sit it out and
then you'll, you and, and, and your talk.
But it clearly is, uh, uh, is
the food for, of knowledge,
the food of the mind, the food of
knowledge, uh, the taste of knowledge,
et Cetera,
all those metaphors.
The bread of life.
Yes. Since that's very good. That's
very good. Because I think, uh,
cannot be also grace.
Yes. That's what it was.
Because we are healing the world of
paradise. And I know that I'm really, I'm,
I'm giving a Chi sort of philosophical,
our emphasis,
but there is also the,
with Paul that is also the fuel.
So we were dealing with a poetic,
more than the philosophic,
the poetic and the theological together.
Absolutely. Very good. Thank you.
Um,
other questions
please. Um, beginning of Canto Lynn,
when he describes how God shed some
more or less pure men light on different
parts, um, the phrase pure of men,
it was also used in purgatory, um,
to describe different
aesthetic perspectives.
Is Dante trying to bring that in here or
is he just talking about the hierarchy
of
who God chooses to shed light on?
Well, good, good. Uh,
the question is in a line
three of Paradiso, one,
uh,
Dante uses the phrase more and less
talking about the light that shines on a
creation according to a principal
of more or less. And then the,
the concern is with Dante uses this phrase
quite often in Canto 10 of purgatory,
where in the world context of art, uh,
that is that phrase about approach.
I call it the approximation. Uh, uh,
so it's, it's, it's, it's done to
joining the tool. Does he want us to,
uh,
to,
to put the two things together
and let me answer that far,
be it from me ever to say no.
Dante does not want us to do that.
The whole reading,
I mean,
if there's a principle to the way
I read is that they're more echos.
You can find the better it, the
better. I think that we serve,
whether we understand the appointment,
we reserve what we,
I take it to be the intention of the poet.
Uh,
but I had never really conjoined the tool
in my own mind for one simple reason,
because here I think it's,
it's Dante's asserting the
principle of hierarchy.
I think that improved factorial dentists
doing something completely different.
Uh, since it's the
context, there is pride.
He's really reversing or
forms of, uh, of, of, uh,
what is the measure the human beings,
how do we measure human beings?
I could say that this is
actually a problem that goes
here every time you have a
higher, okay. You know, um,
really placing myself in between
a Noda, a rank, uh, of, of,
of different values. And so I can say
that that is also happening in, in,
in, in a, in Canto one. But frankly,
the context will not allow me
to go far to much beyond this.
So yeah, there is a way in which every
time I talk off of hierarchy, I'm talk,
I'm talking about a rank ordering and,
and therefore the sense of my place.
It's a little bit removed
from the concerns here, uh,
of uh, uh, it's there, it's there,
but not the most compelling
argument for me. Uh, you may,
you may prove me wrong of course,
but, uh, I would say this issue,
uh, appears there. You know,
we can we join things together.
Let's try to keep also each entity in
its home specificity so that we really
understand that the,
the,
how far he's thinking can go with a
representation of a scene than another.
But I like that. Good. I like the
fact that you true joy, you combine,
yes,
we're speeding.
Why people
paradise,
how one would need to know
about philosophy and theology.
And politics in border.
That's the question is
who on earth could Dantes audience B?
We know
who the audience of
Houma Virgil, uh, can be.
Uh, [inaudible] is, uh,
w w what about the audience for,
until someone who has to know philosophy,
theology, uh, and so on. Uh,
and my answer is, you're right, we
do know roughly about Houma, uh,
because after all the,
there is always the modal
course in the all this see who,
uh,
is singing to the audience at court till
your list disappears and their episodes
and Houma, uh, is, is the,
uh, one of the reps holds.
I may be the one who stitches together.
The voices are episodes that
gives us immediate, your, uh,
account of an audience. Um, um,
with Dante is a little bit more
difficult to understand. It's,
I think con,
I can tell you in our contemporary
reports think that Dante is a poem,
especially in federal,
ought to be read in the streets.
Like really [inaudible]
going on the ancient Greece.
They would go from one fair or market
place and the day with the market to
another and gather people together.
They feast days of the community. Um,
but I can be a little bit more
romantic that I think it's true.
Uh,
but that Dante probably did read some of
his cantos when he was in Ravenna and a
over owner to the,
the in the evening gathering the
circles of, uh, of courtiers.
Uh, but, but I don't think
of Dante's a coacher. I mean,
it doesn't seem to have the values.
Pairs are the Socratic values of the mind,
of course,
but he doesn't seem to share the
social problems of the court.
I can think of, uh, some aspects
of Shakespeare being, Eh,
Eh,
the poet of the court,
the poet who would be read
by the Queen and he wants,
he wants the queen to read his,
his texts or the theater.
We know about the theater. Uh, uh,
a part of Paradiso was not known at all.
Some people,
the first time cantors were sent to the
patron who would probably give him a
check. But today we'll call it grant.
You know, you apply for a grant.
They'll give him a, uh, a
gift for, for the great,
extraordinary dedication. That's what
patrons would, the role they would play.
But I think that Dante,
and this is going to be a very
romantics, are Benjamin now, uh,
I think that Dante writes this kind
of poetry at the end to for God.
I don't think that he could
care. Uh, uh, I only has a,
an empirical audience in mind.
He really means that the few,
I don't think it's a
total strategy at the end.
You feel we're going to read that and,
and uh,
it's too much written.
It's written too much in
the mode of a quest for God.
You know, the, the prayer actually,
it's a more a moment at one point where
language bends into a prayer and they're
hit with the language of a longing
that, that, that goes with prayer.
That I really think it's meant for God.
I mean it in a very serious
way and ends with a prayer.
The Great Kanto 33 is what
an extraordinary prayer. Um,
so that's my answer. Uh,
I'm sure that the, you know,
I have a dear friend,
uh,
who wants to make a movie about
reading Dante in the streets.
And that's fine, but
I'm not sure, uh, that,
that's what Dante thought. I mean, I
read them. I'm not sure about that. Um,
great question. Thank
you. So you're excited.